what's happening there reject nation
we're going to watch today superman and
lois hey we do our full-length watch
alongside around lois over at our
patreon page special thanks to all
become superjects if you can't share
your support over there sure to support
by leaving a like today that would mean
a lot also subscribe and click the
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next snl is up on
the channel and then prepper boys you're
the real super boys of the real rejects
thank you guys so much helping us edit
these down let's swing into action
people
until he reveals the location of that
thing that killed our men superman will
remain a prisoner of the united states
government usa
getting the job done
your arrest was sanctioned by general
hard castle herself and i don't trust
you to keep your word so
tell me where he is
ooh cool shot odds at itself there's a
greater threat here her name is ali
alston she's a cult leader
whatever brought your suspect to this
world she knows more about it than
anyone whoever this woman turns out to
be
changes nothing
you will give me the location of my
suspect
or i'm gonna cry
you guys are gonna have to keep
yourselves busy after school okay until
your grandfather and i figured this out
sure you deal with jordan's drug problem
just the two of you i mean jonathan
i didn't really want sophie to see well
i didn't want you to see well this is
what's got to happen right might as well
just get it over with burn it all none
of this is your fault
none of that is yours either
okay
i don't know about that
[Laughter]
take a good hard look at yourself sarah
it's only been one night and it's just
so hard seeing my mom cry all the time
i can imagine
i don't really know if you can
oh [ __ ] the raid all the lockers arrest
her ass still thinking about how sexy
you feel
i i did have a little help yeah and it
worked so
uh yeah i bought you a month's supply
that should last you a while
candace don't worry i'll look you up
with a good price no no no
actually i think i'm done don't are you
out of your mind i can't
everyone i need you to step away from
your locker i'm not that that's a joke
it's for the xk i can't get caught with
this stuff jonathan but you can i'll
dump it i'll dump it okay
you good kid
there's no way they're going to check me
[ __ ] plan
i mean after everything you've done for
humanity to find yourself here do you
ever stop talking
and did i not bring you face to face
with our mother for that good deed alone
i deserve at least some credit i think
how are you deserved
to be locked up in here i love them
together what would you offer for my
cooperation
oh that's messed up
goddammit anderson [ __ ] torture do you
know anything about jonathan kent taking
this drug from the mines whoa no i
didn't know anything about it thank god
yeah but please just promise me not to
smoke space drugs yeah i'm not that
stupid
oh man that sounds so fun
way better than regular drugs might be
good for you to just
vent to a friend a little bit is there
anyone else you feel comfortable talking
to about this john's daughter
do it girl time are you selling drugs no
mom i promise my girlfriend is selling
drugs i am so pissed and trust me
jonathan your father will be too
once he's out of jail
maybe you could talk to him on your way
to jail
i have had
enough
disappointment for the day
so get upstairs right now both of you
god poor lois he's at 76.2 north
longitude 100.4 west latitude
thank you
i think that mayor dean made a big
mistake bringing up the family values
i'm
pretty sure i still have a husband that
cheated on me but you are a great mom
and accusing a good mama being a bad one
is terrible politics especially when
you're the kind of the victim of this
situation i just need to call him out
take the fight to him
get some dirt yeah
what is that your supplier freaking out
well i wasn't one telling drugstore
football team so jeez i don't know why
you're getting all this trouble if it
was someone else's though look i made a
dumb decision can you please just leave
me alone
what's the big deal
so your girlfriend loses her house come
don't threaten me you're not the one
being brought to heal by some barbarous
kryptonite collar perhaps i might extend
my leash by shining a light on all your
many lies enough
is it brother
i think not
oh
any idea what this is
it's that thing's suit
superman must have warned him that we
were coming
they're working together this whole time
superman's been lying to me and there's
the proof no why what a lot of
conclusions you jump to me jeez
prisoners back away from each other now
oh my god use this as a moment to get
out back away or my soldiers will open
fire
of course
my apologies
sir general hart castle's on line one
says he's been trying to reach you says
you're fired check his pulse soldier
do not
damn
dang
oh look here comes the cabaret
zip out of there
you had it coming anderson you really
believe they've been working together
this whole time how else do you explain
what we've seen we have to presume that
everything is part of some plot good
luck giving grass to give a damn i need
a chopper ready to go asap but sir
general heart castle she's gonna take
all my command if i don't prove that i'm
right the best way to do that finish
this
best motivation prove that you're right
what are you gonna do
simple
we uh kill the batman i'm gonna kill my
bad guys i'm bringing superman back
oh
my man
you above the law oh [ __ ] everyone's got
super powers who have you escaped a
prison and have joined forces
no other choice it was glorious mother
two sons of krypton vanquishing action
yeah buddy
the closest to brothers
what drove us apart greed
power
your wife
tried to kill me
oh [ __ ]
geez
yeah
all the women in clark's life are
married to formidable people in other
universes
so i know that i shouldn't have ghosted
you after camp
oh oh oh
oh
i just wanted to say i'm sorry
okay
well then
apology accepted
let's kiss and make makeup my dad
cheated on my mom and i feel like you're
the only person who might understand
childhood divorce to the rescue
he just won't stop calling do you want
to talk to him
kind of
i mean it it just doesn't seem fair to
my mom
but it's not about her it's about you
and if you want to see your dad see your
dad
oh it's also later than i thought so i
should probably get going
uh-huh
maybe we could be friends again
[Laughter]
oh
i better pee old boyfriend if i was
i know he was carrying them but you got
to believe me i think he was just trying
to cover for somebody else
i hope you're right but you're still in
trouble for knowing about this yeah i
know
then what did john do with all that
money
could be paying for lana's campaign he
can buy himself his own john henry suit
i know i feel like everybody in this
family
is great at something
i just i want it to be great i guess
and just so you know i would never sell
drugs
i believe you're sweetie i do
john you're great at being normal
taking drugs like that is just something
i never even
thought you would consider doing
i'll make it up to you do you want some
xk
i know where you can get some easy
friends and family discount
honey i know that you think that what
you are doing is right but sometimes in
life there are mistakes that we cannot
take back
and i assure you this is one of them
i'm sorry
you got great kid damn something is
coming
it's a missile
hello oh [ __ ]
you don't have to do this i'm bringing
you in
all of you
by any means necessary
including you hologram lady whoa
wow
what a dick
that can affect him right
yeah won't break the force field
hahaha
[Music]
[Music]
oh
yes
smash his face
smash his face in
you must disintegrate them
[Music]
not so tough without your inhaler
guys such a dick
no no he's not healing oh time in prison
under the solar lamps
fly and fly him
to the highest point
oh
man
cruel [ __ ]
[Music]
what
whoa no no
[Music]
this heartbeat sounds backwards
[Music]
oh no
fly bizarro to the moon
[Laughter]
anderson escaped but i'll find him what
if the other you
he's dead damn
tell your son i'm sorry
wow
well maybe someday you can tell him
yourself
ha
hate anderson what kind of person you
are
someone so willing to attack a member of
this family during one of the most
painful moments of their life yeah
they're loser that way juice
[Laughter]
news to me wow
can we talk
yeah
you and i are gonna have a long talk
about all the important things i thought
you already knew so that you don't ever
misrepresent yourself or this family
again
music's backwards
yeah that's good catch he's bizarro
in disguise
john dude just rat out your girlfriend
he thought you were dangerous enough
that i should look into you and i have
something that he wants
but i think it belongs to you oh [ __ ]
you
can you tell me what this is
that is the way to change the worlds
i hate this guy so much
he's the worst
[Music]
she said change the worlds he's the
worst
yeah
yeah
[ __ ]
that was so funny that episode that was
the most i've laughed all show all
year long
2022 most laps wow
that was um
that was dramatic that was uh yeah that
was a good tear-jerker episode
everyone's going through some emotional
struggles right now
do you just like
is there something you want to talk
about
no
sure no
you sure no i'm fine i'm fine i can't
tell you
can't rat
on yourself on my own opinion feels like
there's something in you that needs to
come out and he's
so emotional jokes this is banter jokes
that's it this isn't bad
there's no camera right this is just you
and i the therapy sessions
no no not therapy i'm an acquaintance
talking with you okay
purely
mutual friends
that's how we know each other okay so
we'll keep this surface level not too
deep nothing could be uncomfortable but
also nothing too plain
yeah i i feel you
well
jonathan
my dude
suffering the repercussions
it is conflicting
to a certain extent
if i was in his position i would feel
conflicted i would yeah it would be hard
i wouldn't want to rat her out
so i should be like man she's hot she's
into me
i can't lose this never happened
damn
well if i'm the guy who's known to
snitching on his chick yeah
no one's gonna want to date me then
it's hard man well it's her mom i'm glad
he's suffering the consequences of it
and that's like painstaking and
there's there's a lot he has to deal
with and uh he's probably gonna get his
powers at some point so it's all gonna
be early but yeah they don't have
awakened his latent kryptonians yes yeah
he's gonna he's gonna get something so
all right
however um the way how this is all going
for him is really painstakingly awful
and i like the way it's being portrayed
you know like you're slowly watching him
crumble as someone who has just been
really closed off not wanting to talk at
all and then by the end you know would
having your brother come at you having
your mom come at you and then your dad
who you've been like worried about who's
finally home and his first words are
you're gonna get homeschooled yeah
you're expelled and i'm very
disappointed in you what were you
thinking he has to deal with the weight
of that yeah watching it all crumble on
him
was that was rough man that's hard
there's a lot of like family struggles
here you know that's what the whole
episode really dealt with family
struggles
hard times with the family supes and his
brother
his name
yeah yeah i'm watching uh how that all
progressed and you see like these little
shades that there's development and true
care happening i like that they didn't
do like a full swing yeah you know he
takes a couple of shots for him he then
says
i'm sorry to your son
he sort of accepts the plight of the
situation that he's in with being
brought back to the red room
he's like he knows his brother so well
they're like yeah
this lines up this would have been yeah
this is always gonna go
but at least yeah at least i can
understand him a little better and hey
maybe someday i will get to say sorry in
person to jordan and then it's
interesting how they've been flipping a
lot of this around like bizarro dying
there's still a chance i feel like
there's gotta be i feel like
back in some way yeah and i mean you
know he's been just like locked up the
past couple of episodes there's got to
be more for him to do and more for him
to dazzle us with
uh i don't know how he jenna does he has
powers from the sun or would it be
something like he gets it from the moon
is that something i think
i think they address it i mean he says
on this planet i'm not as strong because
of the sun like the sun here doesn't
give me as much power as the sun at home
uh but yeah i don't remember if there's
like a what the equivalent would be you
have like does he because you know like
the moon's light is just reflected off
the sun so i don't know but then again
you know with the mumbo jumbo of sci-fi
you could easily be like whoa special
lunar juju that you know
but yeah i i wasn't 100
clear on that but yeah it's interesting
too they they had that be
you know the the ex kryptonite they
established that in the first you know
glimpse we get into the other side that
like oh there's a lot of it over there
and it's you know the main threat to
bizarro superman so
yeah that that enhanced the stakes of
his fight with anderson
you have this like little hand grenades
basically he's able to blow up on him
yes
that was uh that was brutal
it was mean-spirited
yeah this means angry character that
anderson
props to that guy
because uh he he's
he's good at that character because i do
hate him
but uh i think the actor does a good job
making that happen in a way that still
feels
you know
well
mixed into the show
yeah
he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] guy [ __ ] [ __ ] man [ __ ] bird i
don't like him at all never did never
trusted him the show wanted you to not
trust him from the get-go
freaking sam's not close to being
retired no he's making calls all day
i don't understand what it is he's doing
hell it does work ever since he come
back
what he does is he he does not have a
retirement going no the only difference
is now he can make calls from like his
fishing boat which he's never on anymore
yeah he's just tending to more of this
military family
turmoil but yeah when bizarro died yeah
that is a that's a tough choice you know
and i like the foreshadowing early on
about to give you guys
i'm about to
give you guys
a visual
clue
if i was to do a breakdown of this get
ready to be super duper
impressed with what greg's about to tell
you are you ready mind blown in three
two
one early on in the episode he is being
told you know bring me your other self
bring me bizarro and it's doing a
profile shot cutting back and forth
between superman talking with anderson
and then when it cuts superman on his
profile the what superman's looking at
he's seeing a reflection of himself the
reverse of himself
and early on he's being presented with a
choice do i save my brother who's being
tortured in the cell with me or do i
save myself
and then at the end of the episode
he makes the choice
he saves his brother
visual references thematically
overshadowing what's happening there
before our eyes oh it's like they knew
it was gonna happen with the beginning
of the episode even though it wasn't
done yet mind below
are you not mind blown that's called
picking up on film making
visual
details
i don't know about you but i'm impressed
yeah
and
then uh lois man lois and jonathan
whenever they're having some type of
coral that's always so
emotional
so heartfelt man i like that they do
weave through the gray areas
you know like i'm disappointed in you
but i still love you
there's a common rhetoric that john and
i have every day
you know
i am jonathan in this in in this in this
house is life you are jonathan from this
episode i am jonathan from this every
day yeah
not a two-week time span like this show
every day sorry
and yeah her performance is so solid oh
yeah
i like the way how lana handled that
[ __ ] with the mayor too
flipping his actions on his head this
town
is the definition of sheep
like jesus christ what happened in that
diner in that diner
lo long gang got [ __ ] going on her ass
she don't know what she do how can we
try herbie goddammit can't keep her
husband in line
it's a freaking town and then lana shows
up says like two senses are like oh man
i never considered that [ __ ] that
person's circumstances
before i realized how messed up this is
that we're in that lot
well and also too i mean like mayor
dean's talking and like half the people
who were like giving lana the business
the first time were like his best
friends so i'm like oh you don't really
care about smallville you were just
planted there
now anderson's here
what's neat is that this this season the
way it was kicking off would seem like
the main villain would be bizarro
whoever was in that misleading doomsday
suit
that was the kickoff and then now as
we've progressed
it's become ally and anderson working
together toe-to-toe
you know and
now superman has to somehow take them on
while lois has to save
lucy
and then lana
and some other girl with an l name
sam going back to the person who she
cheated on jordan with
the show's trying to tell us
you should be friends with the person
you had an affair with
and it's okay to forgive cheaters
in fact you should cheat just cheat it's
better in the long run and if you can
forgive yourself for cheating you will
be a stronger individual absolutely um
next episode is just gonna be a bottle
of just kyle
yeah
i don't know why she didn't go to
natalie
uh
well
i don't know i mean she's got a
different trauma to deal with in terms
of parental figures so
yeah that's all cool though
you can't go to the person you cheated
along with yeah but you know you gotta
have that like yeah we grew up together
okay that's fair you got up with aubry
yeah she did they went to camp together
yeah but didn't they just since they say
something about before then
and then they just didn't talk since
camp uh you're probably right i don't
know why is she two hours away
well you know people move sometimes when
you get older
you're not
soon enough
i mean i'm not gonna move two hours away
but uh you know seem different uh
i don't know it doesn't matter still
cheated should be excommunicated she
should be executed execute kill george
to find her laser heard it down yes
homeland
right into the eyes
until there are holes through the back
of her head
yeah
yeah
no forgiveness and no gray areas
or should she talk to a therapist that
she should go to betterhelp.com
use our special promo code
betterhelp.com doubletoasted
get yourself some therapy
therapy today yeah so this is uh
this is turmotulis turmutulis
is the correct
spanish pronunciation turmeric
and so yeah guys
i don't know where her house is all
gonna play out there's still enough so
much about ali and what's going on there
she'll be a good guy at the end the
season doesn't feel as
is it's different in the way
excuse me it's different in the way
they're unveiling everything because
last season was pretty simplified it was
a morgan edge guy
that was about it
i don't trust him oh i was right not to
trust him oh wow i mean they had the
steel guy show up too yeah
you know
those two oh yeah that last one was like
oh yeah okay this guy likes lex luthor
actually now you think about it they're
kind of doing similar beats here yeah
guy shows up lex luthor
oh it's not really lex luthor it's
somebody else
and maybe it's lex luthor who created
the suit from another unit like that's
where a lot of us went to with that come
to find out it's not it's actually steel
and the real big baddie is someone who's
a business person
who has followings and it actually has
some supernatural element here that
requires world domination
they've actually just repeated
the same videos
different characters in sprinkle a
different kind of family drama on top of
that they have some friction between
chrissy and lois and there you go
instead of jordan struggling with being
on the football team it's jonathan
struggling with the football team yeah
[ __ ] man this show has no origins no
original ideas or in some ways
it's a deeper understanding of mirroring
effects that reflect
reversal bizarro
think about it a lot of what's happening
is just happening in a different
mirroring sort of way you write down to
anderson the dod you know
he is conflict with the mirror opposite
of sam there you go see you guys this
season's the mirror season from the
first deep
depth
depth hashtag it hashtag depth hashtag
this the deep end all right people
thanks so much for being here i think uh
i think i have demonstrated how
intelligent i am your intelligence
leaves me in awe i love you but i'm
still disappointed
guys
let's do a patron of the day shout out
brian perry
perry white
what connections
to the daily planet dude brian perry i
hope you're having a good march that
you're marching into the month with a
super sense of self worth and value on
the up and up righteous out in the
sunlight bringing hope to everyone in
your family everybody around you whether
blood related or chosen i hope that
you're bringing light into their day and
anything that might be backwards in
their lives or your life you can handle
it man you can set things right and uh
hey we appreciate you being here you
bring us a little extra hope just by
being involved just by showing your
support each month so brian i hope
you're doing well that's the front
headline all right who's the best guy
brian perry love you buddy hope your
2022 is going well and we will see you
next month in another rousing edition of
patron of the day shout outs love you
buddy be well
i was burying a body that's what i was
doing
oh my
we covered for you
brian the camera
cut the camera
cut cut
cut the camera
[Music]
you